- [Interviewer] All right. Pepper.
- Yes, sir.
- [Interviewer] Pepper,
oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Pepper] I'm from Iowa.
I'm born and raised in
Ames, Iowa, Boone County.
- [Interviewer] So tell
me about your family.
You had both of your
parents when you were a kid?
- [Pepper] I know of my mother real well.
Cause I'm like her.
My mother is straight up hippie.
My mother married a Klan member.
My dad's the head of one
of the Klans out there.
So at the age 12, he guy,
he was racing stock cars.
Got in an accident.
Flipped off in the grass.
Killed two kids and got
himself in a body cast.
My dad come to me and he's like, son,
you have to hold Klan meeting tonight.
You're my only boy. You got nine sisters.
How quickly I inventoried myself.
I'm like, I'm not part of this.
I'm a flower child.
1966, July 9th.
I do not believe in your
Klan ways or Klan shit.
Don't force it on me.
It's not of my realm.
I'm a flower child.
Peace and love and pop some pills.
Get high.
Let's make love.
My dad got angry and
said, "You're not my son."
I said, "You're not my dad."
My dad wouldn't be a
coward behind the sheep,
Burning it, burning a live animal was
representing people.
My dad would not be hateful
towards the everyone.
So you see, I come from a family
that's really torn apart by hatred.
At the age 14, I left.
I told my mother, "Mom, I
need to get up out this shit."
I mean, he just smashed it.
Same table eating.
I'm sitting with a
butcher knife in my hand
with a fork saying "God, I
wish you'd say something to me.
So sick of your shit."
So at the age of 14, I got my first car.
I was working at Hormel slaughter house.
The youngest worker there,
but my friend owned it
and I told him, I need to leave soon.
I can't live in this house
with this hatred, this guy.
So when I hit 14, I got my Nova
and I really didn't want
to leave my mom behind.
"Like mom, get in the car.
Let's go."
She's like "I can't.
He'll come looking like last
time and beat me again."
Like "Mom, how many, how many beatings,
beatings you gotta take
every week for nothing?
When he gets drunk he just beats on you."
I take every week for nothing.
So you see, I was forced to
inventory myself at a young age.
What do I really want in life?
What am I?
Who am I?
Am I? And you know what?
All my life I've been
searching for one thing.
And I know I'll never find it.
A father and son relationship
like the rest of the people.
Something I, I don't have.
I mean, I can have all
the money in the world
but can I buy true love
from a dad or something?
No, you can't.
So you'll see, I pack up my bags.
I'd saved up like $2,300.
I'd been stocking on Chevron gas cards.
I knew I had to leave home.
I couldn't deal with this no more.
My mother begged, "Let me
give you all my life savings.
Make sure you're safe. When
you gonna come back home?"
I'm like, "I'm not. I'm not.
As long as he's alive.
I'm not. I'm not part of this.
You cannot force that.
It's a shoe that don't fit.
Don't so understand?
I'm a flower child.
I'm a off-breed of the hippies.
The next generation, the hippies is us.
I need to live my life
and make something of me."
I swore to myself from, from a young age
I'd never be like my dad.
Well I don't know how my
dad had it happen or what.
I don't know the issues. Nothing.
I know he had some gunplay.
He got half a finger. It's
a stubby, but it's half.
Well, when I was working at Hormel,
I had an accident.
One of the saw bands broke and flew up
and I had time to go like this.
I amputated tip of my fingers.
I'm like, "Damn it! Mom,
look. I'm like my dad.
I told you I didn't want to stay here."
She's like "No, baby. You
lost the tip of your finger.
Your dad has half a nub."
Like "Mom, it's an omen. I gotta go.
I gotta go."
That was part of it.
My hand started looking
like my dad's hand.
And my mother swore up and down
"Baby, you still damn
near your whole finger.
Just the tip of your finger was cut off."
I'm like "Mom, it's still
a stubby. Still a stubby."
She's like "No, your dad
ain't got no finger now.
You got a messed up part of a finger now,
but you got a finger now.
It's not a stubby."
Mom did everything she could.
I just say, mom tried to
give me all her life savings.
I told her "No. I'm man.
I got 21 Chevron cards
with $160 worth of gas on it.
I got like 14,000 in my pocket.
I can't do this no more."
My mom passed me a backpack.
And I called her a week on the road.
I found over, over half a million dollars
in part of my backpack.
She did it. Her money.
She gave, she gave me her savings.
She's like "You're mommy's boy."
I had no idea. What am I supposed to do?
I asked mom. I told her "I'm a man.
A man meant to survive
and live off the land."
It was all good.
Well, that year Christmas,
I got in with a girlfriend,
a full-blooded Blackfoot Indian girl.
For seven long years,
I lived in Arkansas on
the Blackfoot reservation.
The best years of my life.
Guy, I didn't know shit til
I came to the wilderness.
I know what plants to eat.
I know what plants to make medicine.
It was the, the time of my life
cause I learned so much
from that, from that woman.
When I got older at 21,
I married that woman.
No, I had a baby, Maria.
My dad's still alive.
I still don't go.
I still ain't talk, talk about him.
I have no father, have no
father that I wanna mention.
But yeah, I got a father, but
I don't see the evil around.
Okay. I've blocked that off.
Mental, mentally, physically,
you gotta make a choice in life.
What you going to be?
What you going to do.
I am a flower child and that's for sure.
You know, then I come California.
I got involved with revolving doors.
I came out here selling crys,
crystal, or uh angel dust.
Angel dust went to me using crystal.
From crystal I went to snorting Coke.
In and out of county jail for some time.
I'm 54 now. I'm like
"Fuck. Christmas day again.
Now I'm sitting in fucking county jail.
What's wrong with me?"
Why can't I seem to make
it on these streets?
Well, I, I got my uh, 7th Prop 36.
Just couldn't get out of the dope scene.
They get added up to like
10, 12 years probation.
But I kept getting kicked out, kicked out.
But each time they's getting me,
they's getting more and more quantity.
I was drinking excessfully.
So the judge said, "I'm
going to make you a deal.
This your 11th Prop 36.
I'm going to send you to a year of rehab."
I said, "Good. I'll be leaving here
at the county jail shortly."
I'd already had it planned and shit.
I'm gonna take off from the gate.
So I already knew what I was going to do.
Something happened when
I got to that rehab.
The first week, my birth
certificate come to me.
I'm like "What? Ames, Iowa.
I'm a country fuck. I'm a gar."
Then the girl, girl come tested.
I got my first negative
test for alcohol and drugs.
About a week and a half
later, I have my birthday.
I'm celebrating my birthday.
Here I am given a 4G touchscreen phone.
Oh you my friends and stuff.
But it will say, I'm so proud of you.
Then few, few days later,
my California ID come.
I'm like, "I ain't never
had a California ID
I ain't never had no ID at all."
So you see stuff happened in that
we have spontaneously, week after week,
I started learning more and more about me.
I started getting my ID, my
Social Security card came.
My birth certificate came.
I finally knew who I was.
Then I got my third negative
drug and alcohol test.
I'm like, "You know what?
I'm leaving every weekend on pass.
I'm coming downtown LA, I got my BMX bike.
I'm heading to Half Pikes
at the skateboard thing.
I've got a way out.
But all this time at rehab and Compton,
Ms. Ward said "I don't care what you do.
You leave me the wrong way every day,
but as long as you live here,
every Sunday at nine
o'clock, you'll be at church.
That's all I ask.
Don't give a fuck what you do.
Where you go.
Don't give me a dirty and
don't miss a day at church."
So you see, I started to know the Lord.
So I started looking at stuff differently.
I started feeling good about me. Okay.
And that's what kept me
drinking, using dope.
I got nobody give to a fuck.
I wasn't needed.
And there ain't nobody
give a fuck about homeless.
I was wrong.
There are people who give a fuck.
There are people that hurts
even seeing us like this.
Yeah. I'm still on the
street after 40 years now.
It's not because of anyone else.
It's because of me, I
have an authority problem.
Although I'm drug free, sober free.
And I do the work of the Lord now.
I started accomplishing
the stuff on the internet.
I got my first music video ever
last long at all on YouTube.
I did that when I was 46.
I've heard number one
spot this long, top 54.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] You, you were
in motorcycle gangs too, right?
- Off and on, yes. You know.
I mean the motorcycle gang
was cause it was a family.
It was a brotherhood, but I wasn't
in it because I would needed the gang.
I wanted the gang.
Like I said, I was searching for love,
for like a father figure.
Okay.
Well now I know my real father.
Father who art in heaven.
Okay.
That's my real father.
He's the one that wakes me
up every morning, everything.
So next thing, a few months
later, I get Google sanctions,
LA stories on Google.
Three and a half weeks ago, I
got LA originals on Netflix.
Once I stopped drinking
totally with the help
of that rehab, with help me
get my ID knowing who I am,
finding myself, I was able to
stop those revolving doors.
I ain't been in jail or
prison or got a ticket
in six year now, almost six and a half.
But the whole time, I'm a church-goer.
You ever heard of City Limits
on glass part 6th and Glides?
I know my real father.
I, I'm a Christian that
does the work of the Lord.
Okay. The Lord gave me a way out.
I got to know my father.
I know him to this day.
Everyone in life goes through phases.
Okay? Everyone goes through love loss
of family members and stuff.
But if you ever had go through the hatred
that I went through, I wish
that on no person, no child.
Okay. I'm just going to end like this.
Remember, everyone is new,
that everyone is special.
Now everyone has the real
father that they can come to.
You know. I went to pure hell.
I've made it this far only because
the father went before me,
cleared my path as a wreckage.
The father's with me and he comes after me
because I make mistakes too.
I'm well known out here,
half the internet's me.
But this excess costs, costs a great deal.
You must never total
yourself for yourself.
You must go deep with it
and see what really make
your roots stay attached.
You got the choice to make your life.
It's not gonna....
You think I wanted to
leave my mother and my
my ranch at age 14 and hit the streets?
I was forced out of my home.
I was forced by a greater
force than I could control.
And I knew that I made the
choice to take it to the streets.
This is my comfort zone.
The media does it's best
to get its smash on.
We're so fucked up. We're renegades.
Not true.
We're people like you, like him, like me.
People surviving, the
only way we know how.
Just to be thankful.
This is my comfort zone.
The street.
This is where I can be me.
I don't judge people.
I give everyone the same love,
unconditional, unconstitutional. love.
I don't need to know you to
say "Hey, God, bless you.
Have a good day."
I don't need to know
you to "Hey, you hungry?
You need a bottle of water?"
I'm not a rich, rich
man, but in some aspects,
I'm richer than most.
I have a heart that loves
and knowledge that's out in this world.
But that knowledge come by leaving home.
Oh you see, the thing about me,
I'm fighting a few, a few issues.
Not only the racism issue
but I'm HIV carrier.
Okay, just cause I'm HIV carrier
don't mean my life is over.
When the doctor told me
"Pepper, we tested your blood.
You have HIV, but don't worry.
You're not dying."
I said "You're damn right
I'm not. Now I make my mark."
That's another reason why I
started taking it to the air.
I have a dream.
You know Marilyn Monroe's
candle burned out long
before her legend ever will.
I have a message for the young and stuff.
No matter what you're fighting
in life, whether it be
inside or outside your
immune system, don't give up.
If you just tested HIV
positive, don't give up.
There's one third of people
that's a carrier, like me.
I carry. I been infected, don't know how.
I don't shoot up.
I don't mess around,
But, it's not what people think it is.
Okay. You could change any,
any sickness you got like COVID-19.
Your diet plays a lot
in your health system.
Okay? So I tested HIV positive.
I'm a carrier.
I'm losing weight.
Okay? So put yourself
on a high cal, pro diet.
You consume a thousand calories a day.
Your body needs that to burn up
so you stay the same size you are.
A HIV carrier has to eat
twice as much as a person
that's healthy to keep our
immune system up and fighting.
Lot of people don't tell you that.
You see, this is one
of the messages at ACE.
I want to give you young people out there.
We can beat this COVID-19.
We can beat HIV with loving one.
And the best thing I can tell
you is to love one another
like it's the last supper.
Cause it just might be.